france 2022 l'heure du choix comme
chaque soir avec h rennes b reliant bon
sens rennes bon sens marion j - 9 avant
le premier tour oui et en cette dernière
ligne droite marion les deux candidats
qui peine à générer un réel enthousiasme
joue sur la diabolisation de
l'adversaire pour convaincre les
abstentionnistes et les électeurs de
gauche emmanuel macron ne cesse de
rappeler que la candidate du r n est
bien une candidate d'extrême droite
malgré ses efforts destinés à adoucir
son image et du côté de marine le pen on
tire à boulet rouge sur le quinquennat
qui s'achève qualifier encore fière de
pouvoir de lens reçoit où règne la
cooptation et le népotisme est désormais
l'un et l'autre appelle les électeurs à
faire barrage récap politiques signés
natacha minerais et nicolas ouvert
c'est l'histoire d'une petite musique
qui monte et qu'on a déjà entendu
[Applaudissements]
des échanges tendus ici sur le marché du
pertuis mais rien qui puisse
déstabiliser marine le pen pas même les
appelle à faire barrage à sa candidature
pourtant de plus en plus nombreux
ça me confirme dans l'idée que je peux
gagner cette élection présidentielle car
la brutalité qui est exprimé à mon égard
est proportionnelle au chance que j'ai
de gagner cette élection
la brutalité pour certains au contraire
c'est le projet de la candidate
c'est un uniforme je cherche à imposer
au fur et à mesure du temps des gens qui
ont une vision radicale de malades
quelques heures plus tôt à la télévision
marine le pen allait encore plus loin
j'interdirais des uniformes islamistes
vous savez il y a des signes d'un
certain nombre d' idéologie totalitaire
par le passé qu'ils ont fait beaucoup de
mal à notre continent me semble-t-il eh
bien ces signes distinctifs sont
évidemment et dieu merci interdite eh
bien il en sera de même pour les signes
de l'idéologie islamiste
interpellé par une jeune femme voilée
emmanuel macron se défend d'avoir changé
d'avis déjà il ya cinq ans exister dans
le débat le fait d'interdire le voile à
l'université par exemple wire je me suis
toujours opposé à cela je regardais les
cinq ans qui viennent de s'écouler ce
que j'ai changé quelques règles que ce
soit sur le voile non non et là nous
sommes dans une situation où aujourd'hui
il a face à moi un projet d'extrême
droite qui consiste à proposer ce que la
france soit le premier pays au monde qui
interdisent le voile dans l'espace
public toujours sur le grill
sur l'une de ses propositions les plus
décriées par ses détracteurs marine le
pen fait volte face vous pourriez faire
un référendum sur la peine de mort on
peut pas c'est anticonstitutionnel
à 9000 kilomètres de là ambiance plus
détendue jean castex est là pour vendre
son candidat face à l'extrême droite
je me par vos congés insiste là-dessus
parce que
de banalisation
d'oubli tout se vaut au garage en sont
convaincus macron le pen c'est du pareil
au même après 30 heures d'occupation de
la sorbonne le blocage est levé mais pas
les douces
[Musique]
tard était en fait de penser que la
démocratie ça c'est seulement dans les
jambes vraiment je m'étais promis de
faire voter maintenant
le joaillier
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve lundi
voilà et sachez que cet après-midi deux
fédérations musulmanes la grande mosquée
de paris et le rassemblement des
musulmans de france appelle à voter
emmanuel macron au second tour dans deux
communiqués distincts ils dénoncent la
stigmatisation des musulmans par
l'extrême droite le communiqué de la
grande mosquée parlant même je cite de
forces malveillantes qui appelle au
bannissement des musulmans on passe au
traditionnel coup d'oeil au sondage du
jour oui selon notre partenaire ipsos
oprah steria l'écart se creuse
légèrement entre le président sortant et
la candidate du rassemblement national
emmanuel macron est désormais créditée
de 56% des intentions de vote contre 44
pour marine le pen quant au taux de
participation il serait à 71 % au second
tour toujours selon ipsos sopra steria
chiffre légèrement en dessous du taux de
participation effectif lors du second
tour en 2017 il était alors de 74 6 %
exactement
les deux finalistes du second tour
s'accordent en tout cas sur un point le
salaire du pdg du constructeur
automobile s'étaient lantiss ex groupe
psa est disproportionnée oui carlos
tavares directeur exécutif du quatrième
constructeur automobile mondial pourrait
toucher 66 millions d'euros de
rémunération totale en 2021 estimations
de la société de gestion phitrust
actionnaires minoritaires du groupe dans
le détail 19 million de fixe auquel
pourrait s'ajouter 47 millions d'euros
de primes s'il remplit ses objectifs
d'ici 2028 le cas échéant ce serait donc
un record pour un patron français
écoutez tour à tour sur le sujet
emmanuel macron on a suivi de marine le
pen
c'est choquant c'est excessif fondée sur
des montants qui sont astronomiques s'en
aller sans encadrer dans une fourchette
on doit pouvoir mettre un plafond c'est
exactement si on le fait au niveau
européen ça peut marcher c'est l'anti ça
ne marcherait pas si c'était quand
franco français est donc ce qu'il faut
qu'on puisse faire c'est comme on l'a
fait avec l' impôt minimal et la lutte
contre l'évasion convaincre nos
partenaires européens de porter une
réforme qui permette d'encadrer un
moment donné la rémunération de nos
dirigeants bien sûr que c'est choquant
et je crois que l'un des moyens de
d'atténuer ces rémunérations qui sont
enfin je veux dire hors de proportion
quoi voyez par rapport à la vie
économique
c'est peut-être justement de faire
entrer les salariés comme comme
actionnaire moi j'aime l'artiste je vais
réfléchir à huy pas seulement la
participation je pense que dans des
sociétés telles que celles là il faut
réfléchir à un concept qui serait une
sorte de réserve légale de titres voilà
et de son côté le président de cet élan
this john elkann a contesté ce chiffre
de 66 millions d'euros concernant la
rémunération de carlos tavares dans
l'actualité également ce rapprochement
vue entre europe ecologie les verts et
la france insoumise qui pourraient
former une coalition législatives de
juin oui les écologistes s'y montre
ouvert mais veulent trouver un accord
avec les mélenchonistes sur un pacte de
non concurrence et peut-être même sur un
socle commun de propositions alors que
dans la lettre envoyée hier par la
france insoumise aux écologistes mais
aussi aux communistes et au nouveau
parti anticapitaliste
il était question plutôt d'un programme
commun à partir de celui de jean-luc
mélenchon europe ecologie les verts
posent donc aujourd'hui ces conditions à
noter par ailleurs que le parti a
récolté un million deux cent mille euros
sur les près de 6 millions nécessaires
pour rembourser la campagne
présidentielle de yannick jadot un appel
aux dons je vous le rappelle avait été
lancé dimanche soir alors que yannick
jadot n'avait pas atteint le seuil des
5% de voix nécessaire pour se faire
rembourser par l'état et on s'intéresse
à présent mélenchonistes qui sont bien
dans l'embarras la proche du second tour
oui pour eux c'est un faux choix que
leur proposent cette affiche du second
tour aucun des deux candidats ne
correspond à leurs valeurs et à la
société plus juste qu'il aimerait voir
advenir vous voyez ce reportage à creil
dans l'oise près de paris où jean luc
mélenchon a recueilli 56% des voix au
premier tour signé arnaud boutet et paul
montel
dans cette commune de l'oise beaucoup
espéraient ici un autre résultat creil
villes de gauche va devoir comme partout
ailleurs départager les deux finalistes
mais dimanche dernier avec 56% des voix
jean-luc mélenchon a écrasé la
concurrence et cet électeur ne digère
pas son élimination
président les français doré lui un homme
dépité et décider et aujourd'hui on sait
qu'ils n'allaient pas voter pour le
second tour
a creil même la police municipale ne
cache pas sa déception on est content du
résultat
on va partir sur cinq ans de galère là
encore alors maintenant pour qui voter
dans ce quartier populaire on trouve des
admirateurs de marine le pen eymann est
elle pas parce que les réponses qu'elle
ferait du bien et l'âge du départ à la
retraite 62 ans pour la candidature n 65
ou 64 pour emmanuel macron est devenu
l'un des critères vous vous trouvez que
c'est normal de travailler plus
longtemps bien non la vie est déjà trop
duré et il ya des métiers qui sont très
très très dur et quelle région ils
aimeraient bien en profiter avant de
mourir monsieur alain des fois ils ont
même pas tant de fait deux bons ils
arrivent à la retraite et on ne va dans
le rock et des parcours plus loin cet
autre électeur se dit prêt à quelques
sacrifices
ma femme elle a potential moindre goutte
et moi je suis prêt à travailler jusqu
en souffrance en dix ans donc stop loss
and what n'est pas au pouvoir ça ne me
dérange pas tous demandent la prise en
compte des carrières longues et pénibles
ainsi que la revalorisation des pensions
si je peux éviter de qu'on me pousse
jusqu'au 64 65 j'éviterai c'est
clairement le choix dans quinze jours
sera aussi lié à ça si je comprends bien
ah ouais entièrement entièrement
maintenant vous dire si je vais voter
réellement fin je sais pas a creil
dimanche le vote des jeunes a été
déterminant qui a voté jean luc
mélenchon loin de la question des
retraites ces primo votants font le
choix de rester à la maison le 24 avril
quelles que soient les conséquences
je me sentirais responsable évidemment
pas ce que j'aurais pas fait barrage
mais c'est vraiment contre mes idées mes
principes de voter manuel macron avec
ses idées à lui combien d'électeurs de
jean luc mélenchon prendront le chemin
des urnes beaucoup se donne quelques
jours encore pour des sites est
passé maintenant l'heure de notre
chronique du jour week roddick économie
ce vendredi on va revenir sur deux
thématiques qui ont dominé cette
campagne présidentielle le pouvoir
d'achat et la réforme des retraites on
en parle ce soir avec aline riffa et
présentatrice des côtes campagne bonsoir
line le pouvoir d'achat on l'a vu s'est
imposé très tôt dans cette campagne
présidentielle avant même la gare en
ukraine que proposent les deux
finalistes du second tour sur le sujet
bonsoir ashrel bon soir marion alors
c'est vrai cette problématique elle
s'est imposé très tôt dans la campagne
dans ce contexte de très forte inflation
mondiale qui arrivait aussi en france et
que les électeurs l'ont ressenti très
vite alors la question du pouvoir
d'achat marine le pen l'a très vite mise
au coeur de sa campagne pourtant si on
regarde son programme la question du
pouvoir d'achat n'arrive pas en premier
note qu'en quatrième position derrière
des thématiques classiques du
rassemblement national et de l'extrême
droite en premier lieu sur des 22
propositions pour 2022 on trouve donc
l'immigration l'islamisme et la sécurité
de pouvoir d'achat arrivent donc en 4e
position et pour redonner du pouvoir
d'achat aux français marine le pen mise
d'abord sur la baisse de la tva sur les
produits énergétiques de 20% à 5 et demi
pour cent et une tva à zéro pour cent
sur les produits essentiels du quotidien
une centaine de produits elle souhaite
aussi encourager des hausses de salaires
dans les entreprises des hausses de
salaire de 10 points jusqu'à 10 % pour
les salaires bas à moyens donc jusqu'à
4500 euros bruts à peu près de soi 3
smic les augmentations de salaire qui
serait encouragée selon elle par des
exonérations de cotisations patronales
elle souhaite enfin re nationaliser des
autoroutes pour permettre des baisses de
péage de 25% alors pour emmanuel macron
la question du pouvoir d'achat il est
arrivé à son agenda très tôt avant même
le début de la campagne à l'automne dès
qu'on a vu la flambée mondiale des prix
d'énergie que l'on a commencé à
ressentir en france ya eu des mesures
face à l'inflation et la flambée de les
prix de l'énergie sont gouvernement par
exemple a multiplié les mesures les
mesures ponctuelles temporaire il y a eu
le bouclier tarifaire avec le blocage
des prix de l'électricité et du gaz il
ya eu aussi le chèque énergie la prime
inflation
en revanche si on regarde son programme
est bien l'expression pouvoir d'achat
n'est pas mise en avant il est plutôt
question je cite de mieux vivre de son
travail après à travers plusieurs
mesures ils proposent par exemple d'agir
aussi sur les rémunérations à travers la
le triplement de ce qu'on appelle la
prime macron c'est une prime que les
entreprises peuvent verser de manière
volontaire qui est défiscalisé qui
pouvait aller jusqu'à 2000 euros et qui
dans son sa nouvelle proposition peut
aller jusqu'à 6000 euros il veut aussi
un dispositif obligatoire de partage des
profits dans les entreprises qui versent
des dividendes
il souhaite enfin baisser les charges
pour les travailleurs indépendants ce
qu'il faut souligner c'est que dans les
deux cas on ne parle pas d'augmentation
du smic on ne parle pas d'augmentation
donc obligatoire des salaires
tout repose sur la bonne volonté des
entreprises en ce qui concerne les
rémunérations
voilà donc pour la question du pouvoir
d'achat l'autre thème économique qui
s'impose dans cette campagne d'entre
deux tours c'est celui de la réforme des
retraites que proposent les deux
candidats on l'a vu en effet dans ce
reportage la question des retraites
préoccupe aussi beaucoup les électeurs
et pourrait être décisive au moment du
vote alors emmanuel macron avant même
d'officialiser sa candidature à
l'élection il a annoncé son intention de
relever l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite de 62 à 65 ans de manière
progressive d'ici 2032 au lendemain du
premier tour et devant les réticences
que suscite donc son projet il se
déclarait prêt à discuter avec les
partenaires sociaux du rythme de cette
réforme quoi qu'il en soit ce projet
donc qui vise à relever l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite diffère
complètement vous vous en souvenez sans
doute du projet d'il ya cinq ans à
l'époque il était question d'unifier les
quarante deux régimes de retraite et de
passer à un système unique à points
c'était une réforme systémique qui était
en question dont il était question est
aujourd'hui on parle plutôt d'une
réforme paramétrique on agit sur un des
paramètres de la retraite de son côté la
candidate du rassemblement national
marine le pen promet une baisse de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite à 60 ans
mais uniquement pour ceux qui sont
rentrés sur le marché du travail très
tôt avant 20 ans en revanche ceux qui
arrivent sur le marché du travail entre
20 et 24 ans et demi il pourrait partir
à la retraite jusqu'à 62 ans et puis
ceux qui arrivent plus tard ce marché du
travail c'est-à-dire à partir de 25 ans
devront attendre 67 ans pour une
retraite à taux plein merci beaucoup
line pour cet éclairage donc sur les
retraites et sur le pouvoir d'achat
c'est tout pour ce soir on se retrouve
donc lundi prochain merci beaucoup à
tout les deux restez avec nous ont
marqué une courte pause on se retrouve
juste après
[Musique]